[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview
a first look at what is on the front
pages
it's time to see then what is making the
headlines with the consultant editor of
the daily mail andrew pearce
and the associate editor of the daily
mirror kevin mcguire welcome to both of
you great to see you
as over there let's take a look at the
front pages the telegraph reports that
supermarket bosses
are deeply concerned that they may not
be able to keep operating
if food supplies are disrupted and if
any more of their staff
are pinged by the nhs covet app
the metro has the same story their
headline shelf
isolation the sun declares pings are
running out
the daily mail sums up worries over
supermarket food supplies the so-called
pimdemic and senior politicians
in quarantine the icar is a feature on
the situation with the headline
shutdown replaces lockdown meanwhile
reacting to the government's offer of a
three percent pay increase for nhs staff
the mirror asks
is that really all they are worth the
guardian reporting
nurses are threatening to go on strike
over the offer
and the financial times has a story
concerning the private equity firm
bridgepoint advisors so andrew kevin are
here with their choices come on to
pingdemk in just a moment first of all
kevin your paper
daily mirror reaction to that three
percent offer
yeah what a far say the government was
going to announce it around lunchtime
didn't until
t time because there were arguments
behind the scenes over the actual rise
itself but
three percent in previous years may have
been considered the
uh quite a big offer but not uh after
one a pandemic
two inflation is forecast to hit four
percent so it's a real
terms uh cut then in scotland
workers are going to get four percent in
the uk as a whole
wages are expected to be going up eight
percent although that's partly
uh because young low paid workers lost
their jobs
but that's the figure eight percent the
government's forecasting why he didn't
want to
operate the triple lock on pensions and
the royal college of nursing
had asked for 12 and a half percent so
you could see why
nhs workers who get clapped by the prime
minister indeed saved his life
have worked throughout the pandemic
saved many many lives the nhs gets the
george medal
but they don't get the pay rise that so
many of those workers felt they deserved
the government's recommendation of the
pay review body was one percent
i suspect that was calculated to be so
low so they could then later come up
with a higher figure through the
independent
and pretend it was generous but it's
gone down like uh yeah
it's gone down like a bag of sick yeah
the guardian suggesting um there's now a
threat of a nurses strike
over this uh derisory the uh the head of
the royal college of nursing suggesting
it amounts andrew to two pounds a week
for nurses not even enough to buy a a
cup of coffee
well um the government are saying it's a
thousand pounds a year for nurses
um porters will get 540 pounds
look it's a lot better than one percent
which was derivery
uh i'd perhaps prefer it had gone higher
than three percent but even in
even in nicola sturgeon scotland where
she's always one step ahead of boris
johnson to try to
out maneuver him she's given four
percent only one percent more the welsh
government
uh labor has been dominated by been
labor ever since
wales had devolution three percent as
well
so of course in an ideal world you'd
want to give the nurses more money
but actually most workers in the public
sector are getting no pay rise at all
there's a pay freeze
because public finances are in a
catastrophic state
because of furlough and remember most
people on furlough
private sector meant they've had often a
20
pay cut in the last year so of course
it's easy for the mirror to attack
and the labour gov labor will say we
would have given them what they haven't
told us what they would give them
actually
they certainly wouldn't have agreed to
12 and a half percent or 10
or 7 they'd probably try to get away
with four or five
but uh of course i'd like to see nurses
bake more they've done an amazing job
but so a lot of other people in this
pandemic too
and i have to think some of the people
who get overlooked in all of this those
stoical people who've been
manning the shelves in the supermarkets
on the tills
in this stocking up the shelves uh they
probably got pay rises of but virtually
no pay rise at all
but they never get clapped either so i'm
not trying to diminish
what the nurses and doctors did in the
nh in the pandemic
but there were lots of heroes too yes
the police federation
i don't begrudge a single penny of the
three percent pay rise for our nhs
colleagues
but for my colleagues those police
officers who absolutely played their
part during the pandemic
to be ignored by a pay body which has
had its hands tied by government
is the ultimate insight school leaders
describe the confirmation of a pay
freeze for teachers
as completely unacceptable and an
insulting slap in the face
that's the pressure from the public
sector meanwhile the private sector
one reaction to angela rainer standing
in solidarity to uh
nhs staff caught my eye this is from an
event manager
we get it but in the last year millions
have lost jobs
businesses savings homes excluded
completely had to start again
corporation tax increases for employers
drowning in debt
where has the outrage been for all of us
vocal support
even now and this is the tricky thing
isn't it um stark public finances kevin
devastation for many in the public
private sector and historically as we
know
more generous pensions in the public
sector paid for you know with decades to
come for everybody
yeah well no solidarity from that uh
event manager uh although i'm sure that
event manager if they're
ever sick will be very grateful for the
nhs loaded straight dividing rule
boris johnson was both uh prime
minister's questions
how the economy is bouncing back how
jobs are bouncing back how
vacancies are up and wages are rising
pretty
uh pretty rapidly more rapidly in the
private sector
the public sector and because some
people have had it a terrible
battle there are let's not forget the
excluded you've got no support at all
on the government but to try and just
divide and rule
uh i think andrew was doing as he was
praising others
to try and do down nhs workers asking
for more is a very traditional
tactic of uh the conservatives on the
right of uh
politics it works uh rather a lot of the
time
i'm not really sure it's gonna work now
because all those plaudits that medal
given the
the nhs all that clapping and then
what three percent pay rise when
nation is predicted to be going up four
percent now that is
a cut in living standards it's not going
to solve the problems for the nhs
going forward where staff are knackered
and demoralized and they're gonna have
to be there on the front line
to get down those waiting lists which
are soaring to record levels
if you're gonna retain people and you
wanna motivate people you've gotta pay
you more that is it
and andrew will say well that's not the
money well where do you get 200 million
quid for a vanity boris bought
from there's always money when you want
it there's a 2.2 trillion debt it's got
it's got to be said
but that shouldn't be paid off on the
backs of nhs workers
okay um we'll leave that there as you
say there are
a lot of nhs vacancies which is partly
no doubt what is
what has driven this let's move on to
the story that pings are running out as
the
sun put it uh your paper two in the
daily mail shocking toll of ping demick
is laid bare
this is real world consequences of
rising cases isn't it andrew
yeah but it's uh the ping dam that this
pin this wretched uh
app i'm afraid more and more people i
know have just switched it off
or they're ignoring it it's just over
sensitive and i can't
believe the government are going to
continue with this
all the way until the middle of august
because we might as well just stay in
lockdown because
so many businesses are going to be
flattened by this
because they haven't got the staff yeah
pubs have been struggling
now supermarkets supermarket shelves are
being laid bare
because there aren't the drivers there
aren't the staff stat shelves
uh there'll be shortages people will
start panic buying as well kevin maguire
would be panicked stricken that he won't
be able to get his daily sausage rolls
and he probably won't be able to get
them
but it's becoming a serious problem and
i think the government have got to
get wise to it uh because and and this
i'm just
saying about this app as well i checked
my app the other day
and it said oh you don't have to um you
don't have to isolate anymore
why didn't i have to because it
obviously doesn't ping very loud
so clearly i've been out and about i'm
having a very nice time
and i was supposed to isolate it's
ridiculous okay
yeah i mean it doesn't say check it
every day does it i suppose um
you can close your mouth now i have to
say um you know is it just a case um
kevin of the
the app being too sensitive amidst a
variant which is 60 more transmissible
than the last variant which was
more than 50 transmissible than the one
before i mean you know what do you do
about it boris johnson said it's one of
the only things in our armory
yeah it is in part uh anna but
let's not forget on august the 16th the
government's going to change the rules
so if you're double vaxxed
you won't have to isolate if you've been
in
contact with somebody who tests positive
you have to take daily tests
and the argument from the cbi or other
businesses
for some time is why not bring that ball
and start that now rather than later
because
the telegraphs listing uh some of the
supermarkets that are having problems
they've got their sainsbury's tesco
morrison not every uh every shop uh
so it may not be your local shop but an
increasing number of uh
shops and the telegraph has a whole
other
list so this is becoming a serious
problem it's in the nhs it's also
in in transport and if you're going to
do it on august 16th
why not just earlier because if you if
you're double vaxxed as the government
keeps telling us you're
pretty much protected although there is
look uh why not do it earlier instead of
waiting until then otherwise
as the eye rather neatly puts it a
shutdown is replacing lockdown
uh yes the daily telegraph leads on the
pandemic disrupting supermarket food
supplies
also talks about johnson's vaccine
passport scheme um very very quickly
andrew
blindingly obvious the pm said today
that he shouldn't bring this in before
september
to make it fair for young people but it
appears that it may not get through the
commons what's the story here
well a lot of tory mps don't like the
idea of any compunction about a vaccine
password and i must say
i'm rather with them on that if
companies want to do it voluntarily of
their own accord they should
but he wants to bring them in for night
clubs and maybe other venues as a way of
encouraging
people under 30 to get the jab but um
labour
indicating along with the lib dems that
they'll vote against it and with tory
rebels it's probably dead in the water
anyway
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now
andrew pearce and kevin mcguire welcome
back to both of you so
um we're back to that intractable
problem of how to
square a round circle in a square hole
or whatever
the phrase is andrew and how do you
protect the single market
and protect the integrity of the uk
bellyaching and foaming at the mouth
over this um because of course it's a
real problem and they've got problems
with supermarket shelves there too
because
uh the we are goods from britain that
going into northern ireland have to be
treated like they're still in the single
market because
of the deal that we've done but if the
good dup had voted for theresa may's
deal
there'd have been no border in the uh in
the in this in in the sea
so and they've only got themselves to
blame in a sense but the point is
britain says we can get around this very
easily there's very limited trade
between britain and northern ireland
anyway
in terms of what we do do with the eu we
do about 250 billion pounds worth of
business
this is just a few million pounds worth
you can have you can get around this
with a trusted trader scheme
it has been done before it can be done
again because the goods that
the the the single market is basically
protecting goods
that are at risk which might potentially
impact on the community
european union community but god said
we've been flogging sausages
and processed meat and cold meat to
northern ireland for decades so it's
very easy
to have a trusted trader scheme but not
but so far
the eu is saying no that's the answer
that's what britain wants to do but thus
far we're not getting there before kevin
starts barely aching about boris said it
was another ready scheme
i know he did if we hadn't got that deal
through the commons brexit would not
have been done
and that would have been the greatest
portrayal of democracy in decades
yeah you just you just betrayed northern
ireland
uh anyway didn't you as a unionist look
david phillips deal kevin do you believe
it and they didn't look shouting won't
make any difference
david frost lord frost the brexit
minister now saying there's problems
he hailed the deal he negotiated as
excellent that's what he said
look he's made a big mistake about it
you just tried to ignore the northern
ireland dimension and the problem
with these peculiar political
circumstances there
because of the troubles and the
international
treaty with the republic of ireland it's
your
it's your mess not the european unions
you all wanted to take back control
you just played blindly into people's
prejudices
and into myths and as dominic cummings
and we can question
what he says about boris johnson
absolutely right when he says it is
perfectly
reasonable i think brexit was a mistake
andrew
it was yours a bit rich for kevin
mcguire
not blame anybody else it was
your mistake gentlemen can you believe
kevin mcguire
is quoting dominic cummings as some poor
great hero a man who broke every single
rule in the public health rule book
a man who's bitter twisted and a liar i
don't want to take any lectures from him
kevin about brexit
now you followed him and the brexit
campaign his interview
his interview with laura koonsburg
yesterday was like prince andrew with
with um uh the bbc two news night an
utter disaster from beginning to end or
his own self-reputation
you are all over dominic cummings like a
ration
not me mate not money
sadly i have to draw this to a close
amusing as it is i have to say
lovely to see you both